[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD SEROTER: Hey.
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Richard.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN
RAMAN: Hi, I'm Vidya.
RICHARD SEROTER: We're really
glad you joined us here today.
We're going to have a
lot of fun talking tech.
And I wish you could be
here with us personally,
but we're live at least.
And that means we can
kind of say anything.
Like, I could say, Google
should bring back Google Reader,
and I'm still working here.
So that's awesome.
If you have other
hot takes, you want
to share some feedback,
put it in the chat.
We can see that stuff live
right now, so keep it coming.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN
RAMAN: If you can't
see the live
interactivity, please click
on the blue Join Live
Interactive Experience
button on the next
website and we'll
see you on the other side.
For those of you just joining
us from the Spotlight session,
you heard about some of our
new product announcements,
including Anthos for VMs, Anthos
Multi-Cloud API, and the Google
Distributed Cloud.
RICHARD SEROTER: Awesome.
In the next 15
minutes, we're actually
going to show you all of these
in action, which is great.
So, here's what we're
going to do together.
First we're going to migrate
something and demonstrate
how to get some new
value from an old system
by moving VM-based
applications to a newer
containerized platform.
And we'll start by showing
you how to run a legacy
app in a serverless platform.
So buckle up, Vidya.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN:
Next, we'll create.
We'll build a new
experience for customers
through our AI powered
software, and then we'll
deploy with some
brand new deployment
tools, unique to Google Cloud.
RICHARD SEROTER: Love it.
Finally, we're going to be
expanding our deployment
targets.
We're not just shipping
to Cloud anymore,
but extending that
awesome path to production
to other public clouds and
even closer to your customers
at the edge.
All right, so let's switch
some things up, shall we?
I now work at Cymbal Shops
probably because of that Google
Reader crack.
So let's pretend that
I am the director of IT
at this company, Cymbal Shops.
And like many of you,
our global business
has been shifted because of
increasing demands online.
And at the same time,
we have some problems.
So old software was never
meant for all the customer
load we're putting on it now.
It's holding us back.
We're trying to offer mobile
experiences, real time stuff.
We have to do it
as quick as we can.
And look, I can't
rewrite everything.
So how do we reduce some cost
and add some capabilities
to that existing
software a little easier,
without much too much effort?
So I want to start with a
smart migration approach.
I want a repeatable,
efficient way
to move old systems to
newer stuff, maybe even
a serverless one,
but Cymbal Shop
needs help from our trusted
partners at Google Cloud.
Help, Vidya.
You're my only hope.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN:
I got you, Richard.
So our fit assessment tool,
which you can see here,
is initiated from the
Google Cloud console.
It helps us understand what
can be automatically migrated
and which workloads
are going to be most
successful in their new home.
It's unique to Google
Cloud and saves you time.
By pointing our migrate
service at a set
of over 2,000 virtual machines
in our on-prem vSphere
environment, we just
generated a fit assessment
for the workloads running
in each of those VMs.
And remember, these VMs could
be running on Prem, in Google
Cloud, in AWS, or in Azure.
So now, let's take a look at
the results of the assessment.
See here, we have a graphical
view of our most likely
candidates for migration.
This tool is particularly good
at detecting compatibility
for older Java applications,
like Java EE application
servers.
Now that we have
assessed, let's migrate.
Using our migrate service,
I'm taking a Java app
running on WebSphere
in an on-prem VM
and generating a
container image that
can run on any of our container
services, all via automation.
And you can see here that the
classic Java app is now served
up by our only
pay-for-what-you-use serverless
container product, Cloud Run.
RICHARD SEROTER:
Wow, I love that.
So this is great.
Let me make sure we notice
what we just did there.
I mean, I don't have to manage
all these partially utilized
virtual machines anymore
because you containerized it.
And I've offloaded some of the
operating system management.
I don't have to
patch OSes anymore.
That's awesome.
And you've actually
given me access
to brand new functionality
and saved me money
by running on a modern
platform, like Cloud Run.
So you just took
a classic Java app
and ran that on a
serverless platform.
That's pretty wild stuff.
If you like that,
tell us in the chat
that you have a need for putting
some of your older systems
in these newer platforms.
All right, so next up,
let's create some new value
and get that to Google Cloud.
So Cymbal Shops has some
problems we want to solve.
We have a app that tracks
some of the store performance,
but it runs in VMs.
And it needs some
serious modernization
to support all those sort
of new customer experiences
and can keep us competitive.
So this means upgrading
functionality and even changing
how we could deliver
it to production.
So curbside pickup,
super hot right now.
How do I add functionality then
to count how many customers
did curbside pickup each day?
That seems really important.
Vidya, I don't know.
Can you help me with this one?
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN:
Yes, of course I can.
So, Richard, what does your
current app consist of?
RICHARD SEROTER: Well,
thank you for asking.
Our current app has a MongoDB
database with multiple services
that track orders and pickups.
We actually want to add
new services and data
to capture and analyze
that curbside pickup info.
And to make that
happen, we could
look at historical
footage from the past day,
and count the pickups, and
do some analysis later.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN: This
looks like a great opportunity
to do two things.
First, we're going
to add Google Cloud
AI to process video footage
and capture metrics.
Second, we'll containerize
these workloads
and put them on a
continuous delivery pipeline
so that it's easy to
keep making changes.
RICHARD SEROTER: I like that.
So if you do this,
then we actually
know how many customers
are doing curbside pickup,
maybe even how long
they were waiting.
And I think you're
going to fix them
on my path to prod and
make it easy to package
and keep changing the
software over and over again.
I love that.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN:
Yes, absolutely.
Check it out.
So Google Cloud Vision
API can detect vehicles
in this footage to determine
how well curbside pickups have
been going at each location.
So now, let's write some code
and deploy the updated app
to Google Cloud.
This is exciting.
And I'm hoping all our
audience is excited too.
I'm using Visual
Studio Code here,
but I could easily use
IntelliJ or any JetBrains IDE.
And using the no-cost
Cloud Code plug-in,
I can easily browse Google Cloud
Services, add them to my app,
and then code and test
this container-based app.
RICHARD SEROTER: You are the
fastest coder I've ever seen.
That was remarkable.
So that was pretty simple too.
I like that.
So now that everything
is working locally,
how would they then
deploy this to the Cloud?
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN:
Let me show you.
First, they need to package
up this app into a container.
You probably want your
developers spending time
writing code, not Docker files.
And we can help with that.
I'll show you how we like
to package containers.
And while I'm doing
that, audience,
tell us how do you
package your containers.
So here is our poll, and we
have four options in our poll.
So I'm hoping you would
actually pick it up.
RICHARD SEROTER: Awesome.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN
RAMAN: So Cloud Build
is a serverless built tool
that many customers use
for continuous integration.
We also now support
industry-standard Cloud
buildpacks to package up a
app into a container image
automatically and push
it to artifact registry.
Artifact registry stores
your container images
in regional repositories.
And here you see
that we automatically
scan for vulnerabilities.
RICHARD SEROTER: That's neat.
What else do we use
artifact registry for?
I haven't seen as
much about that.
Can you tell me a
little bit about that?
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN: Yeah.
So while we use
artifact registry
for storing docker
container images, Richard,
we can also use
it for storing all
your language-specific
artifacts in one place.
For instance, we just went GA
with Java, Node.js, and Python
packages using the Maven
NPM and PyPI repository
formats respectively.
RICHARD SEROTER:
That's pretty cool.
So while we're waiting
for the poll results,
looking at some of the chat,
I saw some questions about,
how do we do day two management
of migrated workloads.
I think the migrate tooling
gives you a container image
that now I could
download to my desktop,
I can run in different places.
I have different
ways to run that.
Some other questions
about, again, thinking
about how do we migrate
to GKE and Cloud Run?
I think these tools are pretty
cool that they can actually
take an app and run it in either
one, which is pretty great.
And I think we're seeing
the poll results coming in.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN: Yeah, it
looks like the results are in.
And it's amazing
that a lot of folks
are already automating
today, and they're
automating via Docker build
commands in CI pipeline.
That's excellent.
So now that we have a
container in the registry,
I think it's time to deploy it.
So to deploy our app, let's
use the new Google Cloud Deploy
Service, a continuous
delivery service for deploying
containerized workloads.
While the service is
containerized and could
run in GKE or Cloud Run,
the app is fairly coupled
to our MongoDB infrastructure
running in Kubernetes
and is part of our
multi-cloud strategy.
So let's target one of our
GKE Autopilot clusters.
GKE Autopilot is the fully
managed Kubernetes service
where Google Cloud
provisions, scales,
upgrades, and troubleshoots
the cluster for me.
Here we see a
deployment pipeline
that helps us manage release
candidates and environments.
Cloud Deploy helps us
manage promotion and rollout
across these environments.
And once the app is
deployed to GKE Autopilot,
you can start using it from
each retail store that you have.
You kick this all off
with a push to git,
and also you manually approve
final promotion to production.
In fact, I'm going
to have someone drop
the URL in the chat
window now so that you
can see it for yourself.
It all works just like magic.
RICHARD SEROTER: That's cool.
It must be true.
You put the link there.
That's great.
So it's awesome.
So from development to
packaging to deployment, I mean,
I think, personally,
this is the best
set of integrated tools
for services and building
containers that I've seen.
So I think that's awesome.
So we're also seeing
some other folks
in the chat talking about some
of these components as well
and what they're
seeing for migrating
the apps and, hopefully,
clicking links
and trying to break the
app we just deployed.
All right.
So now that we've just
taken that existing app,
we added AI functionality,
we dramatically
changed the knowledge
that each of our stores
has about the
customer experience.
That's pretty cool.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN: Indeed.
Isn't it, Richard?
What else do you
want to throw my way?
RICHARD SEROTER: I
think we got some time.
So we've acquired a
few other retail chains
who use different clouds.
I mean, nobody's perfect, right?
So at the same time, this app
needs to run in more places
so that each of those
stores can analyze curbside
pick up behavior, regardless
of what cloud they're using.
So I guess, Vidya,
my question for you
is, how do I run
this app everywhere?
VIDYA NAGARAJAN
RAMAN: Yeah, that's
a great question, Richard.
And we do have a
solution for consistency
across any environment.
Check out how we do
it through Anthos.
With the new
multi-cloud API, we can
provision these clusters right
from the Google Cloud CLI
or console in other
clouds, including
AWS and Azure, where
you already had
some applications installed.
See here that I'm using a single
GCloud command to create a GKE
cluster on Azure.
Here, we have
deployed GKE clusters
to Google Cloud and
Microsoft Azure.
I'm managing it all
from Google Cloud,
and I'm even able to centrally
deploy and view workloads
to any of these GKE clusters.
RICHARD SEROTER: That's wild.
Thanks, Vidya.
So you're actually
putting GKE-- and I
think it's the best Kubernetes
in the public Cloud--
anywhere I want it.
I mean, that's really
powerful stuff.
I love that new Azure support.
And again, each store manager,
whatever Cloud they're using,
can actually see a report
at the end of the day
to know how they performed
on curbside pickup.
That was the goal.
All right, but
now, you're making
me think that we could
probably even do more, right?
We could expand
some of our thinking
here and maybe respond to the
customer demands in real time.
Could we actually evolve from
that after-the-fact analysis
of parking lot footage
to maybe improve
the experience in real time?
By that, I'm
thinking of, could I
run this AI model against
live camera footage instead
of recorded stuff, and maybe
be able to do something with it
as it happens?
But of course, as
always, new challenges
emerge if we think of
something like this.
So off the top of my head,
we'd have to somehow customize
this AI model,
because now I have
to identify the number
of cars in motion,
how many are waiting, is
the curbside lot picking up.
And I probably want to
operationalize that model
and move it closer to
the store, because I'm
processing data in real time.
So latency matters.
And then I want to
integrate all that insight
I'm getting with the
existing in-store systems
for the managers
to use so they can
move their employees around.
So that's a lot of stuff.
I don't know.
Can you help me with that?
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN: We can.
So, I'm calling in my
colleague, Gabriele.
He has been working with one
of your on-prem locations,
Richard, in Austin.
And he can explain how
we improve your software
for edge scenarios.
Hi, Gabriele.
GABRIELE DI PIAZZA: Hi, Vidya.
And hello, everyone.
Glad to join you, Richard.
By the way, congrats
on your role in Cymbal.
What you're asking
for can be solved
with our newly announced Google
Distributed Cloud on the Edge.
As you mentioned, it brings
the best of Google Cloud
to the Edge.
It consists of a
fully managed CPU,
GPU optimized platform,
with a common set of Google
and third-party applications.
You build once and
deploy anywhere.
As an example, here at
some of your stores.
So let's get going.
We're going to add real time
intelligence with AI models
and process the data locally
to reduce video latency.
Let's get these running
on the Edge in each store.
So we start out by first
using Google Vertex AI.
So, we train the engines and
the visual objects recognition
and classification models
in the Central Cloud.
Here we are monitoring
the progress and accuracy
of the model.
And as you can see,
the train models
can now be packaged
into container images.
Those container images can be
ready to be deployed anywhere,
including in the Edge.
In this case, we'll be targeting
five different Cymbal stores.
From the Google console, we can
choose the Kubernetes clusters
running at specific
Edge locations
across all the Cymbal stores.
Once we pick those clusters, we
can deploy the vision AI model
that we created to
each Edge in the store
and manage those
Edge clusters just
like any other GKE clusters.
The Cymbal operations team has
the same familiar experience,
only now Cymbal can also
leverage the GPU optimize
Google Distributed Cloud to
achieve better performance
at lower latency.
And as a fully managed
service, Distributed Cloud
comes with the same
integrated Google Cloud
operation and
management capabilities
that you're used to.
Here, Cymbal can monitor the
health and state of their store
deployments, manage
capacity scale,
all of these using a
familiar Google console
and backed by Google
SRE practices.
So as you can see
in the video here,
a real time analysis of
curbside service level
from the live footage
led to real time insights
for Cymbal shops to build a
better customer experience
at each store.
Specifically, this
new model at the Edge
is recognizing cars
in motion, telling you
when the curbside pick-up
lots are filling up,
all executed in real time.
So what do you think, Richard?
Back to you.
RICHARD SEROTER: This is great.
You're amazing, Gabriele.
I can't believe you built
all that all by yourself.
So this actually gives
all our store managers
really new insight into the
real time customer experience,
letting those stores allocate
staff and people based
on real time customer demand.
That's awesome.
So for the audience out there,
I'm actually interested.
What sort of apps do you think
about running at the Edge?
Is that a real use case
you're considering?
What sort of things
might run there?
All right.
So I do love what
you built for me.
I don't want to be greedy,
but I want a little more.
This app isn't an island, right?
You're doing some cool AI
containerized-based stuff,
but there's a lot of things
already at that store location,
right?
Our notification services,
other back office.
It's all in VMs.
So now that we have to integrate
our new customer service
app, these VM-based
systems, am I
signing up for completely
different management
experiences across containers
and virtual machines,
or can you do something for me?
GABRIELE DI PIAZZA:
Oh, absolutely not.
We're going to provide
you the same experience
with the new Anthos for VMs.
We can actually help you
bring those virtual machines
into the Anthos platform
and manage them the same way
we manage containers.
So see here that I've moved
a set of virtual machines
under Anthos management,
which now gives me
a straightforward way
to move and modernize
existing apps at the Edge.
RICHARD SEROTER:
Wow, that's awesome.
There's nothing you
can't do, Gabriele.
That's great.
So what's powerful here is that
all the Google-powered fleet
management in Google Cloud,
other clouds, at the Edge,
is all based on Anthos, with one
open control plane for wherever
those workloads run.
This simplifies our
operations a lot.
Or that open foundation makes
hiring developers and operators
a heck of a lot easier.
All right.
So last challenge for you.
Cymbal has this growing
European presence,
but some of those
regional stores
operate with some restrictions
on data sovereignty.
I don't want to sacrifice
all the amazing development
and management capabilities that
you and Vidya have showed me
today.
So is this a lost cause, or
do you have something for me?
GABRIELE DI PIAZZA: Yes,
we have something for you.
As we announced it yesterday,
with the new Google Distributed
Cloud posted, we can use a
single hardware and software
stack from Google Cloud,
but now with local compute
and a local control plane.
It runs not only our
container and VM workloads,
but also the data
and application
services we care about.
You could run this,
as an example,
with a regional hoster,
fully air gapped,
and have local stores
connect directly to that.
One open modern platform from
wherever you want to operate.
RICHARD SEROTER: I'm sold.
You've done it.
So that's pretty cool.
So same Anthos control
plane tech, but also
local services in this
fully air-gapped setting.
That's great stuff.
Thanks, Gabriele.
Appreciate you joining us here.
And, Vidya, did you like that?
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN:
I did, actually.
And, Gabriele, that was amazing.
And I'm sure our audience
thinks so as well.
Over the last 15
minutes, we've shown you
how Google Cloud offers
a world-class experience
for building new software or
modernizing what you have.
Our solutions for
container-based apps
are second to none.
And we're now making
it possible to extend
those terrific services to
wherever you need us to be.
RICHARD SEROTER: All right.
Thank you all for joining
us, Vidya, Gabriele as well.
This was terrific stuff.
And thank you out there for
the chat and the engagement.
It was awesome to see that.
So now, stay tuned for the
live Q&A coming up next.
We're going to talk
about everything
from the spotlight all the
way through to this demo.
Get your questions in there,
and we'll be answering it live.
Thanks so much.
Bye, bye.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN RAMAN: Bye.